let's go next to
um why don't we go to uh edgar
from florida edgar you're on the air
oh edgar we're gonna have to do
something about uh about your audio
oh yeah okay no problem that's much
better yeah very quick fix
awesome so uh i just wanted to ask
really your opinion
on basically how latin america
deals with their own racial spectrum
i feel like a lot of the times in
america
sorry people may have a underrated
observation
of race relations between you know for
example afro
colombian african colombians and you
know
white colombians for example yes and for
example
in some countries there's a lot of like
there's a big african um colombian maybe
or
or or um ecuadorian population
but maybe not so much in for example
argentina correct me if i'm wrong maybe
you're absolutely right
you're absolutely right no this is a
super important issue edgar
i know that there are some people on the
left
who want to believe the us is like the
most racist country and we just
it's just it's it's disastrous racism
we have problems with race in the united
states that is both
individual racism it's also
structural racism and and the the after
effects
of structural racism that have not yet
been resolved in the inequalities they
deal with
but some of the stuff that goes on there
are many countries that are much more
racist than the united states and i
don't know
i'm not saying argentina is the most
racist country
but because i know argentina because i
was born there
uh attitude there first of all there's
almost no what we what we in the u.s
would call black folks
down there they often refer to black
people
who are just like more what we would
call native
or or mixed populations um they refer to
them as black
and often in pejorative terms
um there is a lack of even understanding
like i remember family members of mine
who don't even realize that the way
they're saying it is sort of
strange would say what is it like the
with the president being black in the
united states and i would be like
i don't know i didn't really think about
it in those terms it's sort of just like
there's a president
um so that's that's argentina and
there's a lot of other examples i could
tell you
there are many countries where the the
issues of racism we could say they're
worse or not as bad
or just different than in the us but the
us is not
you know the the the worst offender of
racism the u.s has tons of people the
u.s has a
horrible history of racism that's
codified in law
and these these are terrible things and
we're still working to fix them and
there's much work to be done
but it's not unique to the united states
absolutely i agree um
wow thanks so much dave and if i could
ask one quick little extra question
you identify as a basically a white
jewish person or like or as argentinian
how would you
kind of word that yourself because i
have an argentinian friend
yeah who his girlfriend like you know
kind of told them but you're white
like ethnically or like you know
whatever you look like a white guy
and he took offense to that like no i'm
argentinian well you know here's what's
really funny about that
by the u.s census definitions i'm
i'm certainly hispanic there's no
question about that because that's
and you can be white and hispanic or
non-white and hispanic so
by the u.s census i'm absolutely
hispanic
i also am in a sense a white guy and
that people see me
as as a white guy and i learned english
young enough that i don't have an accent
in english
except when i'm deliberately
mispronouncing words for the lulls you
understand okay
but then there's another funny thing
which is really my ethnicity
is is ashkenazi jewish like when i do my
dna test
it it doesn't come back you know
european german french it comes back
ashkenazi jewish white supremacists
don't see me as white now why i care
what they see me as
maybe is a different question for a
different day but
the bottom line is i i identify as
a white hispanic that's that's the way
that i
mostly see myself hey same here buddy oh
man i appreciate the time david
all right edgar from florida powerful
phone call
very very exciting